là c'est cet homme a été le chef de la
police fédérale du Mexique sont FBI de
2001 à 2006 en 2006 rennaro casillal
Luna devient le numéro 1 le ministre de
la Sécurité que le président Philippe et
Calderon charge de sa guerre contre le
narcotrafic dont la violence a marqué le
Mexique pendant ces 6 années au pouvoir
et qui se poursuit de nos jours
à présent il est jugé aux États-Unis
pour avoir protégé pendant 12 ans comme
au fonctionnaires du Mexique et jusqu'en
2019 dans le privé le cartel de Sinaloa
en échange de millions de dollars il
comparait dans le même tribunal et
devant le même juge Brian Kogen qui a
condamné le grand chef du cartel de
sinanoa roaching Goodman dit el chapo à
la prison à vie en 2019
ironie du sort c'est pendant le procès
de El chapo que plusieurs témoins des
anciens narcotrafiquants du cartel ont
accusé l'ancien policier d'avoir touché
de fortes sommes d'argent en échange de
protection du clan des belles trains de
leva alors alliés du cartel de Sinaloa
ainsi Sergio viareal baraghan dit el
grande qu'on voit ici lors de son
arrestation en 2010 a déclaré devant le
tribunal que le cartel avait remis 14
millions de dollars en liquide au grand
chef de la police au début des années
un autre témoin affirme avoir donné dans
ce lavotto de Guadalajara 3 millions de
dollars cache en 2018 à Garcia Luna
quand il était ministre en échange de
protection contre un cartel rival alors
où est passé tout cet argent la
journaliste peiner Ramires a passé 10
ans à enquêter comment est venu comment
cet homme issu humble milieu qui a
toujours été fonctionnaire a-t-il pu
être millionnaire en quittant le
gouvernement
pour la chaîne américaine où il visionne
à la recensé les multiples propriétés de
Garcia Luna en Floride dès qu'il est
sorti du gouvernement cette villa en
particulier d'une valeur de 3 millions
de dollars qui venaient avec un quai
privé et un luxueux bateau c'est faux
dit son avocat César des Castro avant le
début du procès l'avocat a dit que son
client allait plaider non coupable
contrairement à ce qu'espérer
l'accusation
ce qui impressionne le président
Philippe et Calderon chez ce policier
c'est sa passion pour la haute
technologie telle que ce centre unifié
de renseignement de la police fédérale
devenu secrétaire à la sécurité Garcia
Luna c'est tout sur tout le monde et
terrorise politique et journalistes
personne ne réalise que pendant ces 12
années de service roi qui ne chapeaux
Guzman se tire de nombreux mauvais pas
et s'évadent deux fois de prison et
c'est l'armée et non la police qui
effectue les arrestations des plus
grands narcotrafiquants
le second homme le plus puissant après
le président au fonctionnaire grand
allié de la DEA américaine était un des
principaux alliés du chapeau Guzman et
du cartel de Sinaloa
de Brooklyn des manifestants avec une
grande bannière qui accuse tous les
partis politiques mexicains tous ces
présidents d'avoir toujours protégé des
narcotrafiquants en particulier le
cartel de Sinaloa du chapo Guzman
l'ex-président Philippe et Calderon a
réaffirmé qu'il n'était au courant de
rien et que jamais il n'a négocié avec
des criminels mais des doutes subsistent
comme pour plusieurs autres présidents
mexicains Andress manuel Lopez sobrador
n'a-t-il pas fait libérer l'ancien
ministre de la Défense le général
Salvador sienne fuegos accusé aux
États-Unis des mêmes crimes que Garcia
Luna
n'a-t-il pas fait également libéré aux
vidéos le fils du chapeau Guzman en 2019
lors d'une opération meurtrière à kulia
Cannes Sinaloa en vidéo finalement
capturer la veille de la visite du
président Biden à Mexico début janvier
Jean-Michel Leprince Radio-Canada
Montréal